[Music]
hey y'all
yeah it's monday today's monday got my
catzilla shirt on
this cat cracks me up come on yeah get
over here we're trying to get in here
way over there trying to like sneak off
the side of the
i couldn't i didn't know where the
camera was so we're going to do one
about the uh the hatchet series we saw
them all we watched them all in about a
two day period
yeah we watched the first five of them
no there's four of them we watched the
first two
on saturday night and then i watched the
last the the
second two like last night they're
they're all free on amazon prime
well no that's not entirely true wasn't
one of them we had the last uh
victor victor crowley which is the
fourth one yeah uh
that one i think was 3.99 but the weird
thing about it though
the first two i think are free to watch
on amazon prime if you have amazon prime
subscription
now three and four i think
if you want the unrated version like you
have to pay to rent them
but to be honest i watched the r rated
version and i can't imagine
what they cut out of those because those
are so [ __ ] gory
yeah that it's like the unrated one
can't be that much
more corey because the r-rated ones are
pretty [ __ ] gory
there must have been some more in there
maybe but it's i don't know but i was
just kidding
that's for the uber fans yeah i guess so
although i will say that like the kills
in this
are super super fun somebody like
already brought up
easily the best kill i think probably
one of the best kill in like any slasher
movie ever
is in the first movie where victor
crowley takes that woman's head i think
you were in the bathroom so you missed
it
but he takes like the woman's head and
puts his hands in there like that and
just basically
pulls her head like yeah in half it
looks so [ __ ] great i love it
yeah being from the south and having you
know going to new orleans a lot and
having friends who are you know
friends and relatives that are cajuns
and [ __ ] with cage is nothing more than
dumb [ __ ] country creole anyway
they're just another kind of southern
person
this this movie is pretty much spot on
uh shows a french quarter used to hang
out there all the time
i can head goth clubs there back in the
days i would hang out there
hung out there at around the same time
marilyn manson and old [ __ ]
trent resner were hanging out there
marilyn mesa says don't go down there
he's right you're gonna end up [ __ ]
one of three places
prison a hospital or a cemetery [ __ ]
uh
you get in trouble down there and uh
everybody i knew that [ __ ]
hung out down there [ __ ] got in
trouble in some way or another
just a bunch of [ __ ] trucks and it's
in the middle of the [ __ ] hood
but it is kind of cool there is a
certain
look to that area and uh
the premise of this movie is basically
friday the 13th all right happening in
the bio
and it's like except funny except it's
funny
well the tone is kind of like a uh
kind of like uh evil dead
in a way what's it that was it mass
versus evil dead or uh
versus evil that's kind of the tone over
the [ __ ] top
gore humor
sex and just amusement and it's kind of
like an all-star cast of like who's
who from the whole horror movie scene
and uh it's got callbacks and shout outs
to all the [ __ ] classics
it's just a good series it's a good
series and they they kept it up over
four episodes
the only thing i would say that would be
close a close comparison in terms of
quality would be that phantasm series
it's a lot like that um it's better than
friday the 13th
oh i agree yeah i know that might be
like a little bit
i mean now some of the friday the 13th
part two is probably my absolute
favorite the first three you're good at
friday the 13th
and the fifth one is good yeah um but i
kind of feel like
these ones although i think the first
one the first hatchet movie is still my
favorite
um all of them are worth watching like
the first one is the funniest
but i feel like the the kills got
crazier
i was gonna say like yeah my favorite
kill is that woman getting her head
pulled in half
but my second favorite kill is actually
from the fourth one which is called
victor crowley
and that was where the one guy's
publicist
victor crowley tears off her arm with
her phone still in
it shoves it all the way up her cooch
and it comes out her mouth
with the phone still going um i loved
that that was very creative
so i really like and i like he he kind
of like tends to pull people in half
pull their arms off he reaches in there
for people's spines and like pulls their
spine and their skull out like through
the [ __ ]
i mean it just gets like wackier and
wackier as it goes there's a lot of good
things about it
about the whole series there's not many
bad things about it i'd have to say
i think the shining star of the movie is
the writing
the writing is very good everything
that's mentioned in the movie
kind of comes up in later movies so they
remember
things i think that these were even that
they came out like the first one came
out in 2006
the second one came out in 2010 the
third one came out in 2013
and the fourth one came out in 2017 but
i think at least the first three
were written to be um a trilogy
okay and you can definitely tell because
one and i think that if you just see
them you know just
as standalones the end of them might
piss you off because they
always end like super abruptly like on a
but
but it's because this the next one like
picks up exactly where that one left off
so you know so you kind of have to watch
all of them it's almost kind of like
four episodes of a show more than four
movies and it's like weird that they
were that far apart
real good casts the acting is good for
this kind of movie the tone is good
it's got um classic [ __ ]
stars [ __ ] show up out of nowhere
[ __ ] and you're like oh it's him
so many easter eggs yeah yeah so many
and i'm sure i didn't even like get them
all
yeah it's weird because okay you have a
lot of directors in the background
playing [ __ ] [ __ ] people from the
scene doing stuff jenny recognizes him
she knows who she knows all the
directors i don't
but she's well and actors that turned up
in other horror other ways too
like a lot of 80s because you can tell
like adam green who wrote and directed
these
um you can tell that he straight up
[ __ ] loves 80 slasher movies
so these are kind of like i don't even
want to say it's like a parody
it sort of is but that's more like a
loving homage
um you know it's just like really and he
seems to know like
what everybody wants to see in these
types of movies it's full
spectrum it is spectacular they're just
wildly wildly entertaining
every single one of them was
entertaining i will say like the first
one's still my favorite one
and i think the third one was probably
the weakest but
they're all worth watching and they're
all like super fun
so there aren't any bad ones no they're
all they're totally all worth watching
and so what ended up happening with this
i had heard of the first movie hatchet
right and i just never got around to
watching it for some reason i was like
kept
mixing up with machete you know i can't
imagine why
but uh then a while back remember when
we were watching that kane hotter
documentary that's on shutter
i think we even reviewed it for the
matinee show and he was went uh
way into like talking about the hatchet
series because obviously he's
uh you know he plays victor crowley and
he plays like a couple other parts
and he was the stunt coordinator on it
as well
so i was just like man i really need to
get around to like watching that series
one of these days because kane hotter is
like a cool dude
and uh so then i saw that they were all
on amazon prime so i said well [ __ ] it
i'm just gonna i thought i was just
gonna watch the first one but then i was
like oh they have all the other ones too
so [ __ ] might as well
yeah uh what's his name todd shows up
tonight
tony todd shows he's in like three of
them he's um
he's very briefly in the first one yeah
and then
in the second one he's like a main
character and then the third one he just
kind of turns up on video because i'm
just a dude from candy band if you don't
know
yeah black dude from candy man he's
[ __ ] great in it sid
haig shows up in it he's in the third
one he shows up
i'm talking about the series sid hag
shows up say hey always blows [ __ ] out
of the water that [ __ ] is
[ __ ] funny funny creepy [ __ ]
oh my god
was it for some reason one of his
funniest lines cause he was only like in
one scene but it's like he really
[ __ ] steals it
yeah i'm pretty sure yeah that was the
third thing that was the third movie
um he just turns up he's this guy that
has like victor crowley's dad's ashes
for whatever reason
and so they show up but he's playing
himself pretty much he's playing himself
and he's just like this cranky old yeah
like [ __ ]
redneck dude yeah and it's just like so
funny it's like for some reason the
funniest [ __ ] that he said to me even
though he said a bunch of funny [ __ ]
was that he's like what are you coming
here in the middle of the night and
she's like it's 8 45.
that's what i said it's like the middle
of the night it's 8 45.
he's basically playing captain spalding
again but it's just not right
but it's basically he always played he
got famous for that act
and he did he [ __ ] chews up the
[ __ ] scenery and does what he does
what's so [ __ ] funny is that the
first time i ever saw him in a movie
was in a [ __ ] alien rip-off what was
the name of that [ __ ]
was that called contamination or no no
that was the italian one
it was 80s and it was it was one of
[ __ ]
um cameron's first movies it was a it
was a roger corman
roger corbin movie he was in he plays a
character that basically doesn't speak
he has one [ __ ] line
and he gets he had these weapons that
were these crystal shards
and they go to this alien planet and a
piece of [ __ ] crystal shard jumps up
his arm
goes up his arm slowly into his heart
and kills him and [ __ ] that scene
freaked me the [ __ ] out
and when you're a kid you don't know who
sid haig is you know what i mean
i didn't make it because he there was it
to be kind of towards the beginning of
his career
and it was a trip later on when i
[ __ ] revisited that movie again and
all these years that was sid hague
played in that [ __ ] character when he
was young
he was actually in a movie from the
60s the late 50s early 60s called spider
baby
the name cheney jr i remember the name
of the [ __ ] movie it was called
[ __ ] galaxy of terror
that's right contamination was the
italian alien ripoff yeah that's one was
galaxy of terror was the roger corman
alien rip-off yeah
some of you guys might want some of you
guys might want to revisit
galaxy a terror it was actually a
well-made [ __ ]
roger corbin ripoff movie it was so good
that the
[ __ ] cameron got selected
to do [ __ ] aliens too based on his
work in that [ __ ] movie
and and that's the only movie i saw
where a big old alien
caterpillar rapes a woman yeah and
that's a whole in the scene
it's a [ __ ] trip man that move is a
[ __ ] trip but anyway back to this one
but yeah so yeah so tony todd is in this
uh
briefly in the first one robert england
is in it oh thank you
jack uh very very nothing it's just like
a little
i can't even actually tell what that is
what is that it looks like a marshmallow
maybe a little marshmallow it's a little
happy marshmallow yeah
but yeah so robert england is in this
very briefly in the first movie
i'm trying to think of like all the
[ __ ] people that show up in the third
one
not only is sid hage in that but one of
the main characters
is caroline williams who played stretch
in texas chainsaw 2. um
you got now in the first movie you have
a character named mary beth who's kind
of like a
recurring character throughout now she's
played by
uh i can't remember the name of the
actress from the first one uh
i want to say maybe it's uh tamara
feldman or something like that
now she was replaced in subsequent
movies
with um the chick that played the little
girl in halloween four and five
you know what i mean uh yeah so she
turns up as a main character as well she
takes over
uh mary beth in the second one a main
character who plays mary beth's uncle
is [ __ ] tom holland the guy who
directed the original child's play
and the original fright night and he's
like a character in that movie too
people turn up in this oh and in the
fourth one
there's like a flashback in 1964 at the
beginning
and the guy at the beginning is jonah
ray
from the new mystery science theater
yeah that's right
i had forgotten that he was i didn't
even like no i was like hey is that
jonah
what the [ __ ] i know he's probably been
in other stuff but i didn't like realize
i was gonna like see him there
but it's just kind of like so many
[ __ ] people
turn up in this i can't believe i didn't
know about this series
nobody even mentioned it yeah and like i
said we were only just i'd kind of heard
of it around the periphery but
yeah um i had only i was only reminded
of it because we watched that kane
hodder documentary
it's got a lot of southern humor in it
cultural references and [ __ ]
yeah danielle harris thank you some of
the cast actually is southern i can tell
by the accents that the woman that
played that cop and
that's a real southern accent probably
you said texas
well she's she wasn't a cop she was a um
reporter
reporter that's what it was well like i
said that was the same chick from texas
chainsaw massachusetts
yeah so some of the people had real
southern accents and [ __ ] sig
sic sid hague must be southern because
his accent was
spot on well he always liked talks like
that yeah
but i i heard it he was laying it on a
little bit thicker
yeah and i don't know where maybe you
guys know where he's from but he sounded
southern
to me yeah wouldn't surprise me um
just [ __ ] good series i didn't know
about it we just found it kind of by
accident we're scrolling through and i
said what's that and
jenny went i've heard about that series
everybody's what telling us to watch it
so i said put it on that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] fire well like i said i'd been
wanting to see it because
because kane hotter was like talking
about it and i was kind of like oh [ __ ]
well
i put it up there with hey you know i'm
gonna give credit where credit's due man
i've
put it up there with um phantasm
and uh evil dead and the first
you know three uh
uh friday the 13th even though friday
13th
has very different tone it's dif it's
that that's more classic i was supposed
to be a little more serious
the tone in this one is a little bit
more like phantasm or evil dead
this one's more comedic and a bunch of
homages
to other horror movies that you've seen
with all star cast
and it's [ __ ] violent man it's really
violent
yeah it's super super great yeah super
gory but but hilarious yeah
i mean they're so over the top that yeah
ripping people's heads up [ __ ]
kicking people in the back of the head
where their [ __ ] teeth in the [ __ ]
head goes
[Laughter]
and then the eyes blink i mean i don't
know if this would have scared me when i
was a kid
because of the tone maybe it would have
i used to think
[ __ ] gore was really over the top
especially in friday the 13th
i go back and look at those little
friday 13th movies there's not much in
them
it was all suggestion yeah not compared
to this [ __ ] this shit's like
this is super gory
[Laughter]
yeah on par with evil dead yeah there's
just like [ __ ]
intestines and yeah brains falling out
of people's heads and people's heads
being smashed
it's so over the top it's not it's not
realistic it's wacky but it is you know
what i mean it's just it's good it's
good it's it's it's good entertainment
that's what i mean
it's kind of like it's super gory and
super violent but it's one of those
things where like you said it's so over
the top that it like just becomes
ridiculous and funny
it's got a really good villain the bad
guy
he's like jason on steroids and with a
deformed head
kind of like from the dude from fun
house but he's a
he's a cajun he [ __ ] got a big old
mana hair wearing his [ __ ] coveralls
and [ __ ]
they got a bunch of southern characters
that that are funny you know
[ __ ] cajun [ __ ] swamp rat
[ __ ] on there with his [ __ ] piro
[ __ ] drinking his own piss trying to
he drinks his own piss for some reason
that was like well just because
well i just thought it was funny because
they were like making a joke but i was
like oh don't listen to that guy because
he was like supposed to be like the guy
at the beginning of like
one second like crazy ralph or whatever
at the beginning of the friday the 13th
yeah uh movies where they're like don't
go in the swamp it's like blah blah so
he was that guy but they didn't listen
to him it's like oh don't listen to him
he's
he's uh what they call him jack cracker
or whatever he's like he drinks his own
piss and it's like then they show that
later he does
shotguns trying to [ __ ] hunt
alligator and
just funny [ __ ] man funny [ __ ]
[ __ ] todd plays a character who's
like a tour guide down the french
quarter with that spot on there's
there's guys like that
and he's [ __ ] walking around like a
[ __ ] haitian bokura and [ __ ] where
the [ __ ]
staff with a skull on it and this
[ __ ] top hat it's just good
characters man
white diamond [ __ ] makeup on his eye
with one little rhyme got like a bond
villain yeah with his golds in his mouth
and [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] cool yeah he's only he's
only in one scene in the first movie
but he's like a main character in the
second movie yeah
another thing that cracks me up about
this
is that the kid the guy that appears
in the first one who's like the um what
his character's name is sean he's like
the guy like the asian guy that's uh
driving the swamp boat because i don't
know like the whole plot is that
there's all these guys and they're in uh
new orleans for mardi gras
and one of them wants to go do this
ghost swamp tour and so he ends up with
this really shady like
uh you know tour guide like you know the
boat gets
uh you know [ __ ] up on the bottom and
they like get stranded out in the woods
and then victor crowley starts picking
them off
so it's like this guy sean that's um
running this like [ __ ] shifty ass
tour boat
and it's like at first he's putting on
this really really overdone
like you know creole sort of accent
which is obviously fake
and then even though he's like you know
an asian looking dude
and then like later on when they start
like after all the [ __ ] starts going
down like then he starts like talking
and then he talks like in a sort of
stereotypical asian like over-the-top
asian like kung fu movie kind of voice
and then like after a while
after they it just like [ __ ] starts
going really really pear-shaped then he
just has like a regular ass like voice
like i'm from detroit i'm just like
[ __ ]
but it's just like this whole and the
funny thing about that is
that that guy turns up in every
even though like he dies spoiler alert
like everybody pretty much
everybody dies in this movie so it's
like you know what i mean that's not
really a spoiler it's a slasher it's
just part of the day pretty much
everybody gets killed you have to get
killed if you're in this movie but um
oh i forgot that to mention that in the
second or third one zach galligan from
uh
gremlins turns up in that one too i
think that's the third one also oh and
also in the third one the
main guy that's the head of the swat
team is the guy that played jason
in the remake i think of friday the 13th
so there we go
all right so what oh louis comes in
uh he comes through uh once again with
this information
he said that the late sig sid hague god
rest his soul
was from fresno yeah and my hat's off to
him because he did pull off a [ __ ]
good southern accent and that i i bought
it maybe he did time in the south or
something i don't know
but uh sounded like a southern dude just
[ __ ] going off the goddamn rails yeah
you had to do it yeah yeah
right but yeah so so that character who
played sean
in the first movie you know like i said
everybody gets killed
but then he turns up in every subsequent
movie except as a different character
and i really like the way they like the
second one it's like he turns up and
it's his brother
and then the third one he turns up like
in a completely unrelated role and it's
like i kind of like the way they sort of
uh
they sort of make a joke out of that oh
i forgot to
in either the second or third one
stephen jeffries who played evil ed
from fright night is uh and he was in uh
976 evil also
uh he turns up as a paramedic in that
one as well and gets
uh killed by i think victor crowley puts
those
what are those like paddle things where
they like do you know to bring people
back their heart
you know yeah and that smashes his head
with those so he gets like his head
smashed with that
so like i said pretty much later yeah
there you go i couldn't remember what it
was called
but yeah so i'm trying i'm like trying
to go back and like remember
like every single person and it's not
just like every single person that turns
up in this it's also
like a bunch of the references that they
made like i think even like two of the
characters were talking and like one of
them referenced
um that movie uh
did it do what the the rise of leslie
vernon or whatever
and they like that like leslie vernon
was a real person just like that found
footage movie was
and uh so they did that and it's just
kind of like
like i said you can tell oh and another
thing too is that sometimes
you remember in the first or second
movie where i think it was the second
movie
where one of the rednecks that was going
out there to look for victor crowley
was this dude and his name was chad
and some one of the other characters
makes a joke about how chad's like a
douchebag name
and then he says oh well at least i'm
not named skip like my brother's name
skip
and then the same actor turns up in the
fourth movie as skip
and i was like oh my god it's like
[ __ ] so it's like sometimes they set
up jokes like
just throw away lines or throw away
jokes like in the first movie or the
second movie and then like it pays off
like way later on they'll have like a
punchline
and it's just like i just thought that
was so so funny because the
the fourth one which is just called
victor crowley that actually takes place
10 years after the events of the
other one you know what i mean with like
the one survivor
and they're like you know now they're on
they wrote a book about their experience
and
all this other stuff because the whole
premise of the movie is that victor
crowley at the beginning
is just like an urban legend so nobody
thinks he's real because he's dead
right yeah um you know he he's played by
kane hodder but his kane hotter also
plays his dad
in the flashbacks so it's kind of it's a
similar thing to jason where he's kind
of a little bit
a sympathetic protagonist because he's
born and he's all deformed
and then he gets killed like in a really
tragic
accident and but he now he comes back as
sort of like he's not
exactly a ghost because he's physical
but he's like
so you can like hurt him like you can
shoot him and it'll fall down and stuff
like that but then like every night he's
like regenerates so it's kind of like
making fun of the whole jason thing
where you can't like kill him but it's
not exactly a ghost he's still like
physically
he comes back anyway but he comes back
anyway so it's almost they kind of
explain it a little bit later like it's
this
some kind of curse where he just keeps
coming back and all this other kind of
[ __ ]
but yeah so i don't know like all of
them are good like i said the first one
is the the best one i think the first
one's funniest
because i liked all the characters i
like like the two porn girls
yeah uh then what are they doing by you
beavers or whatever like that guy's
filming him that comes up across several
films
yeah and then they're like sniping at
each other the whole time it's like that
one girl telling the other your nipples
are dumb
[Laughter]
two porn girls that have to do these
scenes together they [ __ ] hate each
other
so there's lots of tits there's in the
first one there's lots of tits
because it's set at mardi gras so you
see like all the people like flashing
their boobs and stuff and then you have
those two girls
in the first movie too so they just
subsequently like are showing their tits
all the time
i feel like there's less tits in the
later movies but there's a lot
really a lot of tits in the first movie
yeah it sounds kind of kind of like they
told them to knock it off or something
well it was set in the set in the french
quarter in the french quarter
especially bourbon street is kind of
notorious for that
although that's mostly legend if you're
kind of a regular down there
the cops will [ __ ] rest you for that
they they don't let people get away with
it that much i mean
uh maybe mardi gras but you know what i
mean the cops are sick of [ __ ]
telling these tourists to put their
[ __ ] shirts back on
and they'll they'll make moves like
they're gonna
send you to jail then they usually don't
they just haul the girl away and then
let her go they just want the other
people to think that maybe she got
arrested for doing that
yeah well i mean they can't fit
everybody in the gym yeah
and [ __ ] just for boo they're just
boo barleen's orleans parish prison
[ __ ] central [ __ ] lockup is
[ __ ] rough they're not gonna send the
[ __ ]
tourist girls down there and like i said
it's just they're just boobs it's not
anything they're just trying to keep it
to a minimum most of the time i guess
but people come from hundreds of miles
around to go to the french quarter and
get in [ __ ] trouble
and a lot of them don't know how to act
they don't know how to act at all
and they kind of show that at least in
the first movie where everyone's just
like
puking in the street in the middle of
the day because they've been like
drinking for several days straight
and it's not a safe area around that
french quarter is nothing but just
one huge [ __ ] ultraviolet ghetto all
right
and the cops are trying to keep [ __ ]
robbers out of there basically robbers
and killers
and people still get killed in there bad
place
yeah yeah had some good had two good
goth clubs for a while there though
[ __ ] the the convent and the crystal
they probably don't exist anymore
yeah moved out to another place yeah
outside of there yeah
[ __ ] it's a rough area
grampur's hammer says speaking of ghosts
i think i have one
bbs like from a bb gun keep dropping
from the ceiling in my man cave
all of a sudden i'll hear one hit the
floor then see it rolling
thing is there's no venter hole in the
ceiling i think it's a buddy of mine who
died six years ago [ __ ] with me
you don't have a fan up there dude it's
not a ball bearing from your [ __ ]
ceiling fan is it
oh god i hope not well not if they keep
falling down because there's not that
many ball bearings in there is there
yeah there could be [ __ ] a dozen of
them um
i don't know it would the fan blades
would be wobbling and i don't know what
kind of fan would have bearings like
that the roller bearings
i think it's mostly plain bearings that
does seem like pretty weird
i have to say too like last night we had
just like started like to go to bed and
then all of a sudden i guess there was
like some kind of weird power surge
and all the lights came on yeah as well
like suddenly
my dad had a weird thing like that
happened this was uh going back maybe 15
years
in that house in heidelberg he was
sitting there watching television when
he got up he heard something hit the
floor right in front of me looked at it
was a little
um a little catholic icon like a saint
christopher medal
those little icons like that and there's
no catholics in that house as far as he
knows he didn't know where that thing
came from
that's pretty creepy and there was no
place for it to fall from
yeah just heard it hit the floor
gramsci's hammer said the same thing no
fan nothing but tiles
yeah weird my dad saw something like
that happen
but he never got down to the bottom of
it have no idea where a little catholic
icon came from
that seems like pretty common in
poltergeist kind of [ __ ] like which just
random [ __ ] falling out of nowhere
like rocks and whatnot and that
particular living room he was talking
about was
always very creepy it had that
poltergeist being watched feeling but
nothing ever
really happened other than that yeah
yeah i don't know what that deal was
that is pretty weird and what was funny
is that nobody died in that house
although maybe somebody he's not even
old
yeah but maybe um somebody died like
uh and was buried there a long time ago
like under like man well like i said
it's kind of like
[Laughter]
missy mississippi's been planted and
raised and [ __ ] that's
buried over several times so i kind of
feel like even people said oh nobody
died in the house i'm like yeah but
there's probably like dead people all
over the [ __ ] place
yeah catholics
but dead but it was it wasn't it wasn't
some kind of an ancient icon either it
was pewter
from what he said he showed it to me
later when i wouldn't visit he says that
i don't know where that came from he
showed it to me
there's this little oval i think it was
a saint christopher it might have been
another one but i think it was a saint
christopher
and it had a little eye on the top of it
where you could hang it and it was a
little bitty thing about that big
oval it was either i think it was the
saint christopher and we didn't figure
out where it came from
he says i found it right there to my
dad's voice i found it right there
where it came from i got up i was
walking
to the walking to the kitchen and heard
it like that
not looking there it is and i was like
oh [ __ ]
there was no place for it to fall from
is that yours no where'd that come from
i don't know
damn ain't no catholics in this house
i don't know where that came from you
know
i can get in my dad's grill yeah i
couldn't call him ass on the phone and
[ __ ] put him on the shelf
and have him tell a story about them
putting a turkey nest in his mouth
i'd been abducted
my dad is the white friend fred g
sanford
he is an empire
empire jump no
he doesn't have a junkyard though but he
had he's that same [ __ ] kind of dude
he's the white fred g sanford
i tell you what that used to make me
laugh every single time because my
grandma used to love sanford and son
which i don't know if you knew this but
this that's actually like an american
version of a
british show called steptoe and sun okay
uh
which was the same kind of i mean they
were white dudes but it was the same
dynamic they lived in a junkyard
and they were always like you know
cranky and like yelling at each other
and stuff
but um yeah fred sanford calling his son
dummy dummy
yeah that is just still like that it
still makes me laugh nowadays like if i
hear somebody
again can ghosts move objects uh
yes some can
poultry guys can move objects but that's
rspk recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis
most ghosts are just apparitions it's
it's a vision it's something that you
just see
it doesn't interact with you it's like a
pre-programmed recording from the past
but then there's another phenomenon
called called haunting
which is a mixture of ghost and
poltergeist
it's a it's something that can sometimes
be seen
like a holographic image or it looks
real sometimes
it can make a physical
physical manifestations it might open a
door or
or it might something it may cause
something to fall
um objects might move
in that area like a poltergeist
phenomenon you usually don't
see a situation where you see in a ghost
and you see the ghost pick something up
and move it that's not what it's like
you might see a ghost or an image or an
apparition and then a day later find
a vase maybe placed in the center of the
floor of a room
and you just walked out of that room
there was nothing no obstruction and you
come back in the room and there it is
so it moved it but you didn't see it
move [ __ ] like that
yeah that's pretty creepy but things
falling falling
in at mammoth during the poultry guys
we'd see things
you know things would fall or fly like
it was thrown or shot
it didn't move right it could stop
mid-air and drop
before it hit a glass window pane or
something
well and it's kind of a thing where you
don't really see it start to move either
yeah you see it when it moves into your
field of view you didn't see where it
came from you just saw where it arrived
because that's what kind of happened
when i saw that [ __ ] remote control
yeah like i didn't see it come off the
table i just like saw
it was moving like right under my vision
and then i was like what the [ __ ]
already in motion when you see it
usually yeah because at first i thought
that i kicked the table but it comes
from a direction where it's an
impossible like say
behind you but behind you is just a
uh you know a corner of a room nobody's
back there
so how did in it flew you talk about it
too much it's gonna start happening
again
well it's like i think last night it was
some weird [ __ ] i think
that it also turned the tv on out here
not only did it turn the
those lights on and the tv here it
turned the tv in the living room on too
oh did it oh yeah it wasn't just that
room well it didn't felt like a power
surge but the weird thing was it wasn't
all the lights it was um it was the
um the directv thing yeah it was
the two the front tv and the two little
and the two little like we have this
like little laser like colored laser
lights well they're little lighting
effects
yeah but it didn't turn the lamps on it
didn't turn like the bathroom light on
or anything like that just send things
it just turned those two on and the
directv thing but not our tv but it
turned on the tv and the lights
something ramp
i don't know if it was the fan yeah see
i that's what i thought because i had a
thing over my
face like to keep the light out and then
i heard
either something went like that or
something got quiet because i was like
did the air conditioning go off
because i was like i thought the air
conditioning broke or something ac it
was going and then i went like that i'm
like why are the [ __ ] lights on we
just turned those off
yeah it was like it came out
simultaneously yeah they were like
yeah and they came on and they're like
they're not bright but they're like
like mine goes like lamps yeah like they
call it kind of like watery effect and
it goes like from
water yeah yeah but it didn't turn like
the bedside lamps on or anything like
that
it was like it was super super i said
jenny look like
she was looking around what happened it
says they turned on
yeah oh that was weird though because
earlier on that day
or was it the day before that same
lighting effect i put it on the
windowsill
and for some reason i looked at it and
it fell
i looked at it and then it fell right
yeah that was i think that was earlier
was it earlier that same day because i
think you'd put it up on the window
or maybe it was the day it was up there
for about 15-20 minutes and then you
suddenly looked over there
and then and then it fell like it called
my attention over there and
i looked at it and it fell it just
didn't fall far just
fell over on its side yeah it didn't
fall off or anything it just kind of
like it just made a weird noise
yeah yeah uh buttons and gadgets
dr1 or doctor one uh this is gory but
it's very obviously fake gore it's not
like the saw series those are just
horribly gross
yeah this is it's more like i'm like
evil dead
yeah so it's like the the kills in it
are like just
hilarious like you see them just because
they're just [ __ ] crazy you're trying
to go over the top
yeah like i said he just like reaches in
like pulling people's spines out and
there's like a little brain will flop
and stuff like that it's like super
bloody and super like intestines
everywhere but it's like it's so over
the top that it's like funny
and he's just like tearing people's arms
off and crushing people's heads and
stuff like that cutting people in half
of this big [ __ ]
this big [ __ ] long chainsaw and [ __ ]
like that i will say
you know what my one of my favorite
things about the fourth movie
was that uh that one character what the
hell was her character name that the
little uh brunette girl
that came with the movie makers yeah
yeah i liked her i liked her a lot she
was because her
she had like a little bitty i've seen
her before and i can't i couldn't place
her
yeah but um i liked her like little
bitty voice and she was like real
sarcastic like oh
this she just like had some really funny
lines i think she had the funniest lines
in the whole [ __ ] movie yeah graham's
thinking that when he died
he grabbed saying i thought when you
died you just vanished but he's
thinking he's starting to reconsider no
i had the near-death experience
and uh before that i had a spontaneous
out-of-body experience in the army just
laying in bed and got so relaxed that my
head started to feel like it was shaking
and it
started to rattle the microwave that was
near near me and my roommate got up and
goes what is that and he went over there
and walked towards it to look at it and
then all of a sudden i was looking down
on the room
could see through everything i could buy
locate
time got really stretched out like there
was a bunch of extra time
i could beat them two places at once
like i was looking at a wall locker from
one angle and then looking at it from
the other the opposite angle at the same
time and i was like whoa whoa
and it went away
solid matter just looked like vibrant
colored cigarette smoke you see little
particles
going through it if you looked at
something you would just move towards it
it was kind of hard to keep yourself
still anything anytime you looked at
something you moved
to it and if you looked at it too long
you just zoomed in and got deeper and
deeper
you could go into it get smaller as you
went
it's [ __ ] weird only just in a few
then he started
shaking me and uh
i just [ __ ] imploded and then
exploded it back into my body because it
was paralyzed couldn't move
and then he let go of me like that and
i'm drifting back off to sleep it didn't
i couldn't fully wake up it was like
sleep paralysis
and then during that motorcycle wreck i
was riding
and before i even got to the wreck i was
looking at what i thought was a shadow
of myself
on the ground riding a motorcycle and i
started to think about what
what my life was like and then zoomed
back and i was looking at myself looking
at my shadow and i goes where's that
light from
and turned around and there's a big old
white light came down and got me and i
was just in another realm it was like
damn welding arcs everywhere it was like
a world
of 3d energy like a welding arc
faces coming at me and people that i
knew and
life review type deal and then it was
shown that no you got to go back because
this is too early and you had to do this
and that and this remember
oh yeah yeah i forgot to go back and
turn around and looked and just saw the
universe as a big disc
with interwoven colors of timelines and
lifelines and weird [ __ ] and i was going
oh yeah i go right there and i
went back into it and was in the
hospital it's weird
but now you you survive but you don't
survive as a human
you're just like a point of view and you
have memories but not a lot of them
um you have memories of who you were but
that's not really who
that's not who you were kind of like you
have memories of what you did in a video
game but you weren't that video game
character that would be a good enough
analogy of what it's like
you remember like i would remember tom
ross but i wasn't tom ross
that was just a role i was playing and
there's like
other versions of you talking to you and
[ __ ] which is weird like a super version
of you
kind of like a some people have called
that the daemon
and um weird [ __ ] but you're outside
space-time so space-time in the universe
in the material world or a singularity
that you're looking at from outside
is is is wild and there was like a
realm that you would consider be like
heaven
i guess if you went into it you might
vanish you you probably wouldn't come
back out of it i don't think
but it's hard to say you just have
feelings
any anything you add anything you want
to know you kind of get a
kind of get an infusion of that
information kind of like a cat
universal kind of like i used to call it
like a akashic records or something you
know
it's like a universal consciousness like
an internet
an internet of the soul
and and all of it together is kind of
like a god
but it it's not a person it's
it's the force basically that's what it
is from
what they're talking about in star wars
i guess
yeah yeah um yeah so camp guy
brought up evil dead and i think beowulf
18 also brought up
uh dead alive which you've never seen
dead alive
it's an early peter jackson movie that
movie
is crazy yeah
it's so awesome though it's but it's
kind of the same tone as this one where
it's like
just so the gore is just so ridiculous
and over the top that it's hilarious
so i don't know i definitely think we
need to do that one but yeah this is it
like i said these are all on amazon
prime uh the r-rated versions
uh i think all of them are free except
maybe victor crowley which is the fourth
one i think you have to pay 3.99 for
that one
um and i think you have to pay if you
want the unrated versions
of the third one maybe um if i'm
remembered correctly
but these are totally all worth watching
the first one's the best i think
the first one's the funniest i thought
they were all good though but they're
all worth watching
yeah and i don't know like because it
seemed like some people i was watching
like some other like bloodbath and
beyond and some other people
and a lot of people like the second one
the best which i can see that because
tony todd is
the main character in it there's you
know one of the main characters and also
tom holland is in it and that's like
kind of cool
but i don't know i kind of feel like my
favorite one's the first
one and then i think the third one was
maybe the weakest just because there was
a little bit
um it seemed like there was a little bit
of padding in there like there was a
couple scenes that
seemed a little repetitive but uh like
you know we already know this
information we don't have to have
another scene like
explaining that information again but
other than that it's just like they're
all totally worth watching i thought
they were super fun
and it's just really i don't know it's
just like fun to like
[ __ ] this is beer and pizza type of
movies you just like sit and [ __ ]
watch all four of them like all in a row
i would actually recommend watching all
of them like in close proximity because
they pretty much like one follows from
the other other than the fourth one
which is set 10 years later the first
three
are meant to be watched back to back
yeah it's like
binge watching yeah seriously even
though they came out like several years
apart
they're still like because seriously it
it ends like
that's the end and then there's the
credits and then the next one starts
pretty much exactly where that one
finished
off and like i said if you watch it if
you watch all of them together
then you'll pick up like all the three
lines and like you know all the jokes
that they set up in the first one
that they kind of pay off in the later
ones
so i feel like you it's probably better
to like watch them all at once
this must have been really weird to like
see them because you know i think it was
four years between the first one and the
second one so that must have been like
really odd
like to see them like that i don't know
but uh yeah they definitely
they definitely all seem like they were
made around the same time
you know because i guess they were
written written that way
um yeah camp guy said wasn't third evil
dead called army of darkness
yes it was kind of a different location
and plot yeah he went back to like
the middle ages in that one
because he went back in time and uh yeah
with the skeleton
soldiers and all that but not skeleton
soldiers they were just kind of like
you know he was fighting skeletons and
whatnot all right so
um are we are we done i said what i had
to say about it
okay well yeah so check out hatchet
if you're into like 80s slasher movies
because these are all super fun so we
will be back tomorrow
probably talking about a stuart gordon
movie but i'm not going to tell you
which one it is although some of you
might guess
but uh yeah so we'll be back again
tomorrow at around
three o'clock eastern standard time so
we will see you guys again then bye